hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff and of course happy birthday
Paul I know your birthday was yesterday
but I did not release any videos
yesterday so sorry about that now
getting back to the match it's still
1921 Rogers Championship match between
Emanuel Lasker and josé raúl capablanca
this is game 8 I decided to skip game
seven because capablanca didn't really
try anything with the white piece it was
a very short game and a quick draw but I
will put a link to it in the description
below so if you want to just check out
the moves to game 7 just a few quick
easy trades and then they agreed to a
draw but the first link in the
description below will take you to game
7 if you want to check that out now
getting to game 8 Alaska still down a
point in the match and he now has the
white pieces so let's see how this works
out for for both of them last pair with
the white pieces opens with d4 we have
d5 Knight to f3 Knight to f6 sorry about
that
and here we don't have the Queens gambit
declined but rather c4 and c6 so the
Slav defense and here our last three was
for e3 and here a couple of Lanka says
that this is one of the rare lines where
black doesn't have any issues developing
the light-square bishop which is more
often than not a problem in in such
lines so Bishop to f5 before closing up
this cage with a 6 with Knight to c3 and
now e 6 so as you can see the bishop is
now freely developed controlling this
very nice diagonal and it's a much
better position than for example if this
Bishop was inside of this cage for
example on d7 or here and if you want to
develop it via fianchetto then you have
to play beasts b6 Bishop b7 and move the
knight move the rook play c5 at some
point to release the bishop so this is a
optimal setup for black and black has to
be very happy about this Bishop to d3
and here Capablanca more than happily
traded Bishop captures we have Queen
captures and now as you can see
Capablanca has his pawns on light
squares he has a dark square Bishop
which can roam around freely you know on
the dark squares so it's a it's a nice
position and he has a good Bishop with
Knight B to d7 now a kappa blanka and
Alaska
sorry about that castles and Bishop to
b6 just putting in the bishop on this
very nice diagonal and E for now here
Alaska is threatening e5 he wants the
wind material here so capablanca trades
we have phone captures Knight captures
Knight capture screen captures and here
kappa blanka castles probably also
possible is just Knight f6 kicking the
Queen away and then castling but
capablanca has a different idea he wants
to leave the f6 square open for his
queen so here kappa blanka castles with
bishop to d2 and now Oscar wants to
bring his bishop over to c3 to control
this very nice diagonal and now Queen to
f6 couple monkeys preparing Queen to g6
like I said he's still up a point in the
match he wants to trade Queens here and
he just wants to take it easy
if Lasker wants to push for a point then
capablanca will get his opportunity at
maybe take you know a 2.2 lead in the
match maybe so
rook a d1 getting the rook to a nice D
file as the bishop is coming to c3 and
perhaps the position can open up and now
Queen to g6 Capablanca offers the Queen
trade and now you could get avoid the
Queen trade but then maybe Queen to c2
can be annoying it's not like you will
capture on b2 because Ruby one can be
annoying as then white also bill gets in
counter play but still last pair doesn't
want to do anything crazy we have Queen
captures and g6 now capturing towards
the center a very principled reply by
Capablanca HP at first and g6 and Bishop
to c3 now just putting the bishop to are
much more useful Square with rook F to
d8 and rook F e1 and the bush of the c7
now Capablanca wants to get rid of all
of the pieces from the D files of his
rook has nice control over the D file
King to f1 Alaska improves the position
of his king and now Knight the f8 you
might think about why not Knight f6 but
to what is the knight doing on f6 and if
you have some other ideas maybe you want
to play f5 create a nice outpost for the
knight on f6 that is a good plan but
there is no way to actually execute it
because well the e6 pawn is weak so f5
is not an option
but Capablanca finds a way how to
improve his position so first knife to
f8 and here capablanca says that a
student of the game should really study
the movements of the night here so you
consider yourself a student of the game
I usually study how the night moves in
this game
bushra back to d2 while ask her now
Capablanca wants to play f6 get to the
king over into the game via King to f7
and then strike to strengthen the center
and the night from f8 is nicely guarding
this pawn here so with f6 by capablanca
and now h4 lasker doesn't want to meet
the g5 in g4 we have King to f7 now the
king is once again defending the e6 pawn
so first you know first part of the plan
has been achieved now the knight can
return and then choose a different
square with g3 Bell Oscar and now Knight
back to d7 so the knight did everything
it needed on f8 so here
kibou Blancas plan is to get the night
over to b6 to c8 and then over to east 7
and from e 7 which will be the second
part of capo Blancas plan he wants to
get the d5 but that's the third part of
the plan we're a couple Blanca first has
to figure out how to create an outpost
for his knight on d5 last bill goes
Bishop to e3 and now comes Knight to b6
kappa blanka still you know with the
maneuvering with rook to c1 not
interested in b3 once you push up on you
can never undo so y-you know better not
do anything rash rook the c1 and now
Knight to c8 and here rook the e2 by
Lasker just you know improving the
position and here kappa blanka plays
Knight to e7
and finally this Knight really did a lot
it came to from from d7 to F fade then
back to the 7th to b6 to CH the e7 and
like I said now Capablanca wants to get
it on d5 which is an excellent outpost
but the problem is the c4 pawn guards
the d5 square so couple on cuz idea is
he wants to play a six row b8 he wants
to push b5 attack the c4 pawn and then
maybe create an outpost for his knight
on d5 and Capablanca also says about his
position here that the position is
unassailable now I had no idea what
unassailable means so I had to google it
so for those of you
don't know what unassailable means it
means unable to be attacked questioned
or defeated so here are couple Marcus's
about his position that there's no way
for white to push for anything here now
that's a really nice word and I'm
probably gonna use it a lot of times in
my future videos so I do hope you
enjoyed that as well on unassailable
now last cargos look the c3 and here we
have a 6 cup of Uncas now ready to pull
b5 and attack the c4 pawn which defends
the d5 square Alaska prevents it with a
4 and now rook a to b8 again capablanca
is preparing b5 so we have B for my
Lasker here he is ready to character and
give up the d5 square but he wants to
push a5 and create a passport for
himself so capablanca goes for it with
b5 C capture something b5 with a capture
Sun b5 and now Alaska pushes a 5 so
kappa blanka is pushing a little bit but
the end result is that last pair gets a
passed a pawn for himself but on the
other hand the d5 square is now freed
for a couple Monica's Knight Bishop to
d6 first threatening to win the b4 pawn
and here the rook has to move from here
to b3 to defend it because if you play
something like rook to b2 then the
knight comes to d5 with a double attack
against the point and on the rook and
now you can go into some row captors and
c6 Bishop character son before ideas but
it's black who's really it's not the
black is better or anything but Lasker
just doesn't want to allow kappa blanka
to dictate the tone of the battle here
so rook the b3 and now comes Knight to
d5 again with a double attack against
the pawn here and Bishop to d2 just
nicely controlling all of the squares
the knight can go to and also a double
defense to the b4 pawn with rook D to c8
by capablanca and here in this position
the game was adjourned and incredibly
when the game continued
unmoved 30 it was in this position that
Capablanca and Lasker
agreed to a draw because after they've
analyzed the position carefully for
quite some time they decided that there
was no way to push for the win because
if you
if you check out the position okay the
Lasker does have a passed pawn but it's
very hard to push it one such example
will be because for example this rook
and Bishop are stuck guarding the B for
point you cannot move them otherwise
you're gonna lose that so you could try
something like rook e1 to maybe get the
recover to a1 and start pushing your
past pawn but still it really does
nothing for example if you go let's say
rook e8 just getting the rook over here
there's no way to do it or if you try
something like rook to e8 preparing
maybe II five white decides to move the
rook from the e-file which also white
shouldn't do what should really keep an
eye on this square here because there
aren't a lot of breakthroughs in the
position if v is one of the
breakthroughs in the position and the
white really shouldn't allow it but
still you could go rook to a1 and now
you will never be able to push a six
because once you push a six rook e8 is
coming Luke a7 the other rook is coming
over here and you will lose the a pawn
because white will still not be able to
defend it as this rook is stuck guarding
the b4 pawn so it's really not not
possible
so although white does control more
space here white should be better here
Alaska decides it's you know better to
live and fight another data and to over
push something and be down two points in
the match and Capablanca is happy which
has lead in the match so far so he
agrees to a draw which is you know very
nice so I decided to show game eight
even though I mean there wasn't a lot of
fight going on but there was there was a
fight and especially the knight
maneuvering was very nice and also
unassailable you know I'm very happy to
have learned that word so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it game 8 of
the 1921 World Chess Championship match
between a manual asker and josé raúl
capablanca
I would like to thank Jeff graves Fabian
Wieck diamond-plate for its Konstantinos
Mitropoulos and alexander one-offs for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing well the
Capablanca saga and of course checking
up on your suggestions and the if you
remember I mentioned that you're welcome
to send me emails regarding the I will
be reviewing other chess channels and I
don't know
I thought I was pretty clear but I
thought if you are the owner of the
channel because I don't know if I will
be able to review someone's channel
without their approval or without their
permission if I show some of the content
from their channel they might you know
copyright strike me so you're welcome to
suggest channels for me to review but I
will only be able to mention them if you
are not the owner of the channel as I do
not have permission to use any of the
content from there to make a you know a
nice review that's a well pretty much
everything I want to say so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day